a new report shows there have been
shortages at many hospitals of a
critical drug to treat the coronavirus
the fda authorized rem desavier for
emergency use back in may first on cbs
this morning the consumer group public
citizen says the trump administration
has mismanaged distribution of the drug
to some states that needed it
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner has been looking into this
my hands aren't able to
move as well anymore i don't know if you
can see them
34 year old michael goldsmith still
suffers the effects of his battle with
covid19 that began in march
he spent nearly a month on a ventilator
his wife alana
it was very scary especially because i
wasn't there with him
scary and frustrating because doctors
had wanted to put her husband on the
anti-viral drug rem de severe
but his applications to get it through
compassionate use or a clinical trial
were denied
that was the lowest point of the entire
ordeal knowing that he needed this
medicine
and he could not get it more recently
hospitals have reported shortages
of the drug one that medical experts
like dr helen boucher of tufts medical
center say
can help shorten the course of treatment
for a significant number of patients
the longer they're in the hospital
especially in the icu the greater the
risk of getting a secondary infection
and those can be very severe and even
fatal so anything we can do to prevent
that risk
is very important for every patient but
consumer group public citizen
found since july at least 38 hospitals
in 32
cities in 12 states have reported rem
desevere shortages
and further that states that had large
epidemics with more new hospitalizations
often received less remdessevier from
the federal government
public citizens peter maberdue the trump
administration
assumed control of rem desevere
allocations and
distribution and it's not going to the
right places for example the report says
one week in july alabama florida and
georgia reported the most new
hospitalizations
yet ohio despite having fewer new
admissions
and fewer total hospitalized patients
received far
more remdessevier georgia got none
you're basically saying the
administration did not distribute this
drug
the way they had promised to why do you
think that happened
we can't know we just know that the
trump administration
hhs did not follow its own stated
criteria
to allocate rendezvous according to
hospital burden
hhs calls that a fundamental
misunderstanding of its system
with a senior official telling us on
background the government has been able
to fairly allocate distribution of
enough medicine to treat 650 000 people
in a fair and equitable process in a
statement the white house said
anytime the trump administration has had
a request from a governor
for increased supply of rem desevier we
have been able to meet those demands
but some democratic senators have been
asking questions about rem desavier
since may
writing in letters to the administration
that the redesiver distribution plan
appeared to be shrouded in secrecy
maryland senator chris van hollen and
have you gotten responses to either of
your letters at this point
uh no we've not heard anything i think
it's a
indication that the administration does
not want to be transparent
about its decision-making process
and that of course hurts all of us
maberduke says transparency is key
not just for this drug but for future
covid19 treatments or vaccines
if we are facing this degree of
irrationality this degree of
mismanagement
today these kinds of shortages and what
will happen
when we have hopefully a safe and
effective vaccine
we're going to have to do much much
better if we run into a similar
situation with a vaccine
many people are going to suffer well
public citizen also outlines what it
calls manufacturer gilead science's
monopoly over the drug saying that also
has limited supply of remdessevier
gilead on its part says that there is
adequate supply in the u.s to meet
current demand
and that if hospitals don't have enough
of the drug they should talk to their
state department of health
that's in part because hhs anthony says
that they allocate to the states but
then the states make the decision about
which hospitals get
this and how much all right anna werner
thank you anna